♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
SOMETIME IN THE NEXT TWO MONTHS,
A GROUP OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS AND
POLITICAL CONSULTANTS WILL CALL
EACH OTHER ON THE PHONE AND
DECIDE WHO THEIR PARTY’S
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE IS
GOING TO BE.
THIS HAPPENS EVERY FOUR YEARS,
BUT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MEMORY
THIS IS A GENUINELY MEANINGFUL
DECISION.
IN NORMAL ELECTIONS, CANDIDATES
CHOOSE RUNNING MATES WHOSE
SIGNATURE QUALITIES ARE
BLANDNESS AND OBEDIENCE.
A GOOD VICE PRESIDENT IS A LOT
LIKE A GOOD WAITER.
HE APPEARS, TAKES ORDERS, AND
LEAVES.
HE DOES NOT TALK TOO MUCH, HE
DOES NOT EXPRESS INTERESTING
OPINIONS.
WHEN VICE PRESIDENTS SAY THEY
SERVE THE PRESIDENT, THEY ARE
NOT BEING POLITE.
THEY ARE BEING LITERAL.
IT’S A SERVICE JOB.
BUT NOT THIS YEAR.
THIS YEAR DEMOCRATS HAVE CHOSEN
A MAN WHO CAN’T MANAGE THE
COUNTRY EVEN IF HE DOES WIN.
HIS AIDES KNOW THAT, THE
CANDIDATE HIMSELF NEEDS SO MIKE
SEEMS TO KNOW THAT B OF THE COAL
COUNTRY KNOWS, WE JUST DON’T
SEEM TO TALK ABOUT IT.
JOE BIDEN’S DECLINE IS SO
EMBARRASSING TO WATCH THAT THE
REST OF US TRY TO IGNORE IT AND
PRETEND EVERYTHING’S FINE PRINT
MOST OF US KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
WHERE JOE BIDEN’S TODAY SO IT
FEELS LIKE BAD KARMA TO DWELL ON
IT BUT THE VICE PRESIDENTIAL
PICK FORCES THIS ISSUE.
WHOMEVER IS CHOSEN WILL RUN THE
GOVERNMENT IF BIDEN WINS.
ONCE HIS ADVISORS MAKE THAT
DECISION THEY WILL CALL BIDEN IN
THE REC ROOM AND LET HIM KNOW
WHO HIS RUNNING MATE IS.
BIDEN WILL PRACTICE THE NAME TO
MAKE SURE HE CAN PRONOUNCE IT,
HE WILL FIDDLE WITH THE CAMERA
ON HIS iPAD, AND THEN HE WILL
TELL THE WORLD.
WHO WILL IT BE?
IT WILL BE A WOMAN, WE KNOW THAT
MUCH.
BIDEN HAS SAID THAT.
YOU CAN TAKE HALF THE COUNTRY
OFF THE TABLE RIGHT AWAY.
NO MAN, NO MATTER HOW CLEAN,
BRIGHT, ARTICULATE IS GOING TO
SHARE A TICKET WITH JOE BIDEN.
SO THAT LEADS 100 MILLION
AMERICAN WOMEN TO CHOOSE FROM.
WHEN JOE BIDEN SAYS WOMEN HE
WANTS YOU TO KNOW HE MEANS NO
OFFENSE TO THE TWO SPIRIT
COMMUNITIES ALL OF WHOM BUILT
THIS COUNTRY AND HAVE
JOE BIDEN’S GRATITUDE.
BUT IN THIS CASE, BIDEN WOULD
VERY MUCH PREFER A LADY.
SO WHO IS IT GOING TO BE?
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS
ALREADY CAST ITS VOTE OVER THE
WEEKEND.
JEFF BEZOS’ NEWSPAPER ALL BUT
ENDORSED THE SINGLE LEAST
DISTINGUISHED PERSON TO EVER
EMERGE FROM THE GEORGIA STATE
SENATE, GEORGIA POLITICS IN
GENERAL.
A FREQUENT CABLE NEWS GUEST
CALLED STACY ABRAMS.
SHE LOST A GOVERNMENT RACE, THEN
SHE WROTE SOME SOFTCORE PORN
THRILLERS THAT HAVE A NICE
AMOUNT OF HEAT, ACCORDING TO ONE
AMAZON REVIEWER.
SHE HAS NO DISTINGUISHING
ACHIEVEMENTS.
SHE DOES UNDERSTAND JOE BIDEN
PRETTY WELL, THOUGH.
AND THAT IS HER MAIN ADVANTAGE.
STACY ABRAMS KNOW THAT BIDEN
DOESN’T REALLY BELIEVE ANYTHING.
HE JUST DOES NOT WANT TO BE
CALLED A RACIST.
THAT IS HIS KRYPTONITE.
THIS TURNS OUT TO BE GOOD NEWS
FOR STACY ABRAMS.
IF IT HELPS HER GET THE JOB SHE
IS MORE THAN HAPPY TO CALL
JOE BIDEN A RACIST.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT NOT
CHOOSING A WOMAN OF COLOR, A
BLACK WOMAN, ACTUALLY, IS A SLAP
IN THE FACE TO THE BLACK FEMALE
VOTERS?
>> I WOULD SHARE YOUR CONCERN
ABOUT NOT PICKING A WOMAN OF
COLOR BECAUSE WOMEN OF COLOR,
PARTICULARLY BLACK WOMEN, ARE
THE STRONGEST PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Tucker: STACY ABRAMS SHARES
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT NOT PICKING
A WOMAN OF COLOR, ESPECIALLY IF
THAT WOMAN IS HER.
SHE’S VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
IT TURNS AT KAMALA HARRIS HAS
THE SAME CONCERNS.
STACY ABRAMS RECENTLY LOST AN
ELECTION THE MEDIA PREDICTORS
SHE WOULD WIN BUT UNLIKE ABRAMS,
HARRIS IS A JUST THREATENING TO
CALL JOE BIDEN A RACIST.
SHE ALREADY HAS.
>> I’M NOW GOING TO DIRECT THIS
ADVICE TO PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I CANNOT BELIEVE YOU ARE A
RACIST, BUT YOU ALSO WORKED WITH
THEM TO OPPOSE BUSING.
THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF THE
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND SHE WAS BUSED
TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY.
AND THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
>> Tucker: IN THE LONG AND
IGNOBLE HISTORY OF THE GIVE ME
WHAT I WANT OR I WILL CALL YOU A
RACIST POLITICS, THAT HAS TO BE
ONE OF THE GREAT MOMENTS.
KAMALA HARRIS IS SO COMPLETELY
OUT OF TOUCH WITH AMERICAN LIFE
THAT SHE IMAGINES THAT SOMEHOW
FORCED BUSING WAS WILDLY POPULAR
WITH AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
IT WAS NOT POPULAR.
IT IS NOT POPULAR NOW.
WHY?
BECAUSE BUSING WAS PATRONIZING
AND DESTRUCTIVE.
IT HURT EVERYONE INVOLVED EXCEPT
FOR MAYBE THE SELF-SATISFIED
WHITE LIBERALS WHO DESIGNED IT.
THEIR KIDS WENT TO PRIVATE
SCHOOL BUT SOMEHOW,
KAMALA HARRIS DIDN’T KNOW THAT.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT STACY
ABRAMS, SHE’S CLEARLY A LOT
SMARTER THAN KAMALA HARRIS IS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
KAMALA HARRIS WRITE A PORN
THRILLER.
WE DOUBT IT WOULD HAVE ANY HEAT
AT ALL.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN TALKING TO A
NEW CANDIDATE AND IT IS
GRETCHEN WHITMER OF MICHIGAN.
SHE CONFIRMED THAT YESTERDAY ON
NBC.
>> HOW WAS THE VETTING PROCESS
GOING SO FAR?
ARE YOU BEING VETTED BY
MR. BIDEN?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH SOME FOLKS.
>> HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE
THE CONVERSATION?
>> JUST AN OPEN CONVERSATION AND
IT’S NOT SOMETHING I WOULD CALL
A PROFESSIONAL, YOU KNOW,
FORMALIZED VETTING.
>> Tucker: A PROFESSIONAL, YOU
KNOW, FORMALIZED VETTING.
OH, OKAY, AS OPPOSED TO AN
AMATEUR VETTING, THE KIND YOU
DON’T GET PAID FOR.
WHAT IS GRETCHEN WHITMER TALKING
ABOUT?
NO ONE KNOWS.
ASK ANYONE WHO LIVES IN THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN.
THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHY GRETCHEN WHITMER BANNED
THE SALE OF PAINT AND CARPET IN
RESPONSE TO A PANDEMIC.
GRETCHEN WHITMER NEVER EXPLAINED
WHY SHE DID THAT.
IN FACT SHE HAS NO IDEA HERSELF.
PAINT AND CARPET JUST SEEM SCARY
TO HER SO SHE MADE THEM ILLEGAL.
THEN WHEN CITIZENS COMPLAINED
ABOUT THIS, GOVERNOR WHITMER
DENOUNCED THEM AS RACIST.
DO YOU SENSE A THEME HERE?
NO WONDER THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
CALLED GRETCHEN WHITMER.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
WITH DEEP EXPERIENCE PLAYING THE
RACE CARD.
THERE ARE OTHER POSSIBILITIES
THAT YOU MAY NOT HAVE HEARD FOR
FOR THE VICE PRESIDENTIAL PICK.
GOVERNOR GRESHAM OF NEW MEXICO,
SHE SPENT HER FIRST YEAR IN
OFFICE TRYING TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ABORTIONS IN
NEW MEXICO.
SHE CALLED HER OPPONENTS RACIST
TOO CUSTOMER PROBABLY.
WE HAVEN’T CHECKED BUT YOU HAVE
TO GUESS.
THEN THERE IS CONGRESSMAN
VAL DEMINGS, SHE REPRESENTS WHAT
IS TENTH CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
SHE IS NOT WELL-KNOWN BUT HER
APPEARANCE IS WHAT BIDEN SAYS
HE’S LOOKING FOR.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE IMPEACHMENT
MANAGERS DURING THE RUSSIAN
INSANITY.
REMEMBER BACK WHEN WE WERE
PRETENDING UKRAINE WAS SOMEHOW
VITAL IN SOME WAY?
REMEMBER THAT?
WHATEVER.
IF NOTHING ELSE, THE JOB PUT HER
ON TELEVISION A LOT.
>> OUR PRESIDENT PUT HIS
PERSONAL INTERESTS ABOVE THE
INTERESTS OF THE NATION,
CORRUPTING AND CHEATING ARE
DEMOCRACY, AND HE SHALL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> Tucker: AND CHEATING ARE
DEMOCRACY, WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
SHE IS A FORMER POLICE CHIEF,
GOOD FOR HER.
THAT IS A ME SHE BELIEVES IN
ENFORCING THE LAW.
SHE THINKS
IMMIGRATION LAWS SHOULD BE
IGNORED.
SHE LETS POLICE CONFISCATE
FIREARMS FROM CITIZENS WHO
HAVEN’T EVEN BEEN ACCUSED OF A
CRIME.
AND THEN FINALLY, LINGERING IN
THE BACKGROUND LIKE A SHY
TEENAGER IS
SENATOR AMY KLOBUCHAR OF
MINNESOTA.
IN A NORMAL POLITICAL MOMENT,
WITHWHICH AT THIS IS NOT, SHE MI
BE THE FRONT RUNNER FOR THE JOB
HE OR SHE DID SURPRISINGLY WELL
IN THE PRIMARIES, BOTH IN SWING
STATES.
SHE’S RELATIVELY POPULAR,
SERVING IN THE STATES THAT
HILLARY CLINTON ONLY NARROWLY
CARRIED FOUR YEARS AGO SO SHE
COULD HELP.
SHE’S ALSO OLDER, CALMER, MORE
EXPERIENCE.
AT TIMES SHE EVEN SEEMS LIKE SHE
MIGHT NOT BE A TOTAL EXTREMIST.
ALL OF WHICH MEANS AMY KLOBUCHAR
PROBABLY HAS NO CHANCE AT ALL.
WEIRDLY, JOE BIDEN OVER HIS 50
YEARS IN WASHINGTON WAS OFTEN
DESCRIBED AS A MODERATE.
IF JOE BIDEN WERE STILL WITH US
MAYBE HE WOULD STILL BE MODERATE
TODAY.
BUT HE’S NOT PURE JOE BIDEN’S
HANDLERS ARE IN CHARGE NOW AND
THEY ARE NOT MODERATE.
THEY MOVE THE CORE GUYS SO FAR
TO THE FRINGES BIDEN IS NOW
DISAVOWING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION FOR BEING TOO FAR